Stepping on Socotra Island is like setting foot on an alien landscape.
This place is one of the most isolated landforms on Earth.
Located in the Arabian Sea south of Yemen,...
...the island separated from the mainland of Africa...
...between six and seven million years ago.
There are nearly 700 endemic species on Socotra...
...that are found nowhere else on the planet.
Perhaps the most head-turning of Socotra's species is the Dragon's Blood tree.
These strange umbrella-shaped trees dot the island.
Its top-heavy design is actually an adaptation to Socotra's arid climate.
The large green crown provides shade, which reduces evaporation...
...in a place that sees very little rainfall.
This otherworldly gem has experienced threats to its ecology from human development,...
...but the United Nations stepped in in 2008,...
...designating it as a UNESCO heritage site.